what are we doing today don't ask hey so
guys my name is China welcome to code
review series series in which I review
your card except today I'm reviewing my
code from
10 years ago yes we're going to be
taking a look at the very first game I
have ever made and by game I mean
something that I made from start to
finish and actually like publish in fact
publishing aside just making a game from
start to finish like a final finished
product this is it this is the first one
I ever made this was all the way back in
high school in 2012. it was my final
year of high school I was meant to be
studying for my final exams a lot of
dare 24 came around and I was like you
know what
just make a game did I know how to make
games was I a good programmer did I have
any experience no of course not I mean I
was kind of teaching game programming at
the time on YouTube as I was learning it
so I had that going for me but this was
like kind of possibly not a very
responsible decision again going back to
the fact that I was supposed to be
studying for my final High School exams
but aside from that it was a good way
for me to kind of challenge myself and
actually try and make something and a
lot of Dev which for those of you who
don't know is like a a game programming
competition which you have like 48 hours
or 72 hours to make a game from scratch
this was like the compo variant vladim
dare which meant I had 48 hours to make
a game myself I think from memory I
spent one day doing it instead of two
days because I again had to study for
the aforementioned exams So today we're
going to sit down and we're going to
actually go through the code the code of
the first game that I ever wrote and
we're going to probably criticize it a
lot but hopefully it will be somewhat
helpful to some people who are maybe
also learning programming if I can kind
of you know point out my mistakes and
we'll probably just have a laugh have a
laugh at it really is what this is about
because merry Christmas everybody happy
holidays hope you're all having a great
holiday season that's why I'm wearing
this somewhat festive shirt I thought
we'd have a little bit of fun you know
at the end of the year and just look
through
this uh thing so I will actually have
the code Linked In the description below
it is push to GitHub it says six years
ago I don't actually know why so there's
two commits six years ago I don't know
why this is six years ago maybe I like
changed account GitHub accounts or
something I have no idea why this is six
years ago to be completely honest I
think maybe I just didn't have a GitHub
account back then yeah that's probably
it I probably didn't have a GitHub
account back then and I probably
provided the source code because you
have to provide the source code if
you're doing the compo as just like a
zip download and then eventually I was
like I know what git is now let me just
publish it again don't you just love it
when it says initial commit instead of
initial command yeah sign up quality
there now a lot of dare was a bit
annoying and took down like all of their
data from the original pages but thanks
to the power of web.archive.org
we can actually see what that page
looked like so this is a snapshot from
like 2014 which is you know not quite
from you know the date that this
actually happened but it's still the
page you can see my beautiful old logo
over here and uh yeah this is the game
um my first let him dare Gamers made in
about 20 hours as I'm finishing my last
year of school and had sex oh sucks
that's what they were called man to
finish in hand in the next day
absolutely beautiful decision by me like
let's just you know let's just let's
make games came 280 overall which is
like not bad I think that was like one
and a half thousand entries so
All Things Considered not bad uh and
yeah I don't know people seem to some
people seem to like it so
yeah did I mention the game was written
in Java I don't think I did but yeah I
was basically learning programming at
the time I was inspired by Notch not
just because of Minecraft although
everyone basically in high school was
playing it back then I was really
interested in like graphics and I wanted
to learn how to like write a 3D renderer
and so I was kind of trying to learn
programming myself High School didn't
really teach it we just learned like I
don't know HTML that kind of stuff and
so since Minecraft was so popular at the
time I was following Notch seeing what
he was doing and he actually did quite a
few live streams where he just made
games from scratch for laudemdale and
that was just such a huge inspiration
because he just he made a game from
start to finish and it was like all the
footage was there and that was something
so new to me because you know instead of
following some weird tutorial online it
was like here's a live stream here's
starting from scratch like from no lines
of code at all and then at the end of it
you get a finished game and it's within
a manageable time frame like it's within
48 hours so it's not like a game that he
made over months that I would never be
able to basically replicate it was such
like it was a small kind of scope which
was really really hell helpful and super
inspiring and so following along with
like his code trying to learn from it
and then also like I think I had like a
Java for dummies book or something that
I bought or probably convince my parents
to buy that I was also kind of using to
try and learn the language and So
eventually like I did kind of pick it up
and I was able to write like all of this
I guess from scratch within you know the
48 hours and a lot of it is kind of
inspired by Notch and like I guess how
he wrote code as well there's probably a
bunch of stuff here that doesn't make
sense like for example public
synchronized for its start I think like
why why did I use that keyword probably
because I noticed he did that for
example for his like start and stop
functions I think in the main class
which I if I recall correctly were like
called by applets and there was
something to do with some threading
model here as well and I didn't quite
understand that but I was like okay
whatever he's doing that I'll do that as
well so I guess it's interesting I've
probably only ever talked about this
like once I made a video in like a
forest in the Czech Republic called how
I started programming and I think that
video I go into depth about how that
happens so if you guys are interested in
that then check it out I'll link it up
there but you know what before we dive
into this I just want to thank brilliant
for sponsoring this video brilliant have
been an amazing sponsor for like the
last six months or so and if you've been
watching my channel then you know how
much I love brilliant and the reason why
is pretty simple it's because it's
really good any sponsor I work with on
my channel is because I really believe
in their product and I think it can help
you guys or it's something that I use
personally and for brilliant it's both
because brilliant is an amazing online
learning platform with lots and lots of
really high quality courses on various
stem topics it's really useful for all
of you guys learning computer science
and programming they have so many math
courses that can help you make games
such as this one and it's not just
simple stuff like this everyday math
course that you can start with if you're
just getting into math they've also got
some advanced stuff like calculus which
I have personally gone through those
courses to revise calculus because it's
been a while the reason why I
specifically like brilliant is because
their courses are really Visual and
interactive they're have these widgets
you can play with they will quiz you on
the content that they're teaching you to
make sure that you retain the
information and learn effectively and
also in a fun way and that's really
important and the best thing is you can
just try it for free you don't have to
pay anything just go to brilliant.org
the channel and check it out see what
they have to offer and if you do like it
and want to continue using it brilliant
have been nice enough to offer the first
200 of my subscribers 20 off an annual
membership so definitely check it out
they've been a fantastic sponsor on my
channel and they just have a really good
product thank you brilliant for
sponsoring this video so let's play the
game I'm just gonna hit play and here we
have Genesis Again by Ian chernokov
which would be me now uh if we hit play
I won't bother you with the other menus
um basically the the the point of this
game is to like essentially reproduce
with all of these women
that you find on the island to create I
guess babies and what that really does
is it increases your population count
so you just go around having sex is
basically the game now why did I come up
with this idea now I will tell you it
was a hit in high school everyone loved
the secret everyone loved this game in
in high school when we were like passing
it around but why uh oh that's a lot for
I think four's the max you can do now
okay a few notes before you guys get too
carried away you will only ever like
give birth I guess to male babies so in
other words all of these women none of
them are your daughters thankfully they
are all one stuck in a tree they are all
not related to you that is how it goes
and also Additionally you can see they
have like a little tag on them that goes
red once you've already reproduced with
them so you can't like
you know keep going you can't just keep
you know mating with the same woman over
and over again so this is uh this guy's
quite a character you know he doesn't
he's just like once is enough you know
with any given woman on this entire
Island there are I think three maps that
I kind of designed for this and they
were all designed as like images like in
paint.net or something where every pixel
is a tile
um I was struggling to find women here
you know material
um so uh hopefully my wife doesn't watch
this video and so there's also like this
timer down here so you only have five
minutes to execute all of your actions
all of your deeds and uh yeah the idea
is just to get the highest population
number you can and you do that by just
reproducing with more and more uh women
here and I want that this just sounds so
ridiculous saying it out loud uh always
love talking about this game
um the designer correlation between like
you know the visuals and what you see
here this just will increase and the
rate at which that increases is
dependent on how many of these
collisions you've you've had and there's
also like a day night cycle as you can
see it's getting like darker which is uh
pretty cool I don't know why I just
threw that in there I don't even know
exactly how that works but it works and
um yeah and so really this just comes
down to uh getting lucky I guess with
finding uh these women on the island
because what happens is when you do
reproduce since that woman like has
already that female actually the code
refers to them as females when that
female has been uh you know
uh how do I say used up but like in a in
a better way this is the festive Spirit
um here we go so like because that
obviously happens and that that female
has been uh cannot be um used again
uh there has to be like you know some
other new females appearing and the way
that works is they just randomly spawn
in somewhere on the island and I think
the amount of them see I'm finding like
a lot now the amount of them that spawn
in kind of also depend on on you know
how efficient you are with your
reproduction and so
um you can see there's we're getting
quite a lot here and the population now
is like skyrocketing which is good
that's what we want and it's becoming a
little bit more of like a let's play but
I'm sure you guys get the idea of the
game now you can see some of them like
remain lit even though they shouldn't
because they're not in the light that's
just like a little lighting bug I uh I
threw in there anyway I'm not gonna play
out the rest of the two minutes you guys
get the picture Okay so taking a look at
the code how did it all work well we
have this like game.java file there's
actually quite a lot of stuff going on
here and I believe that I didn't I
didn't hear any music working I think
the reason why there's no music working
is because it used to use like applet
new audio clip I checked this out just
before I I recorded this video and there
was no music and there's no music
because I think it used to use some
clearly deprecated functions because
again this was like 10 years ago I don't
even think applets or anything anymore
and that's why that's not working
performance is pretty good like one and
a half thousand FPS I don't think there
was a limit on on like the frames on how
many frames per second it renders like
it doesn't stick to your refresh rate or
whatever but it does only update the
game 60 times per second and all of that
I believe is set up basically in this
run function so what happens is
basically this the game starts up as the
main function in Java we create a new
instance of this class which is called
game and then we set like the frame to
new jframe I don't know why this is all
done in the main function and not in the
Constructor I suspect there's no real
reason for that like this the
Constructor does actually do things as
well but you I don't know why I did it
this way again possibly just not did it
similarly to this and I just copied that
essentially so that's where that style
probably came from and then basically
what we do is we add uh so the game
class itself is a canvas it extends
canvas which is like a GUI element and
you can add that canvas element to the
frame so we create a new jframe which is
like a window in Java and then we add a
canvas element which is what this class
is and being a canvas element uh it can
draw things like it can draw you can
render graphics and it also implements
runnable and the reason why that I can't
believe I remember all this but the
reason why that is a thing is because if
you implement runnable the runnable
interface just has a run function so
it's like an interface so if you're
familiar with C plus plus that would
just be like a pure virtual function and
so you have a pure virtual function
called run which we have to implement as
part of this interface and the reason
why that's the thing is because if you
have a runnable you can basically create
a thread and like in like C plus plus
you know you'd create a thread and you'd
pass a function into the Constructor now
in Java and I might be wrong here but in
Java at least back then like this is
before lambdas this was Java 1.6 I
believe
um and so this was before lambdas were
introduced into the language and so I'm
pretty sure you could not tie a function
into like you couldn't use a function as
a variable like that was just physically
not possible and so what you had to do
instead is you basically had to create a
whole new class with an interface
and then that interface would mean that
you would have to implement a function
so you create a new class you implement
a specific function and then you pass
that whole class instance into like some
API that requires it
and that way it would be able to call
your custom function so in other words
it's kind of it worked in the same way
as like a Lambda or a function pointer
but it had to be wrapped in the class
because you could only pass classes and
that's why when we create the thread
here inside the start function which I
believe the applet automatically called
because again this was in fact embedded
in a web browser as well this game it
wasn't just a desktop executable like
you saw there it was also I believe
something that I could embed into a web
browser because back then applets was
still a thing and so because of that we
had like I think start and stop because
those have to exist or in some variant
of them I think have to exist is there
an applet no maybe not game applet yeah
there is so game applet you can see
extends applet and I believe that has to
applet itself had like a start stop and
I just kind of you know delegated that
to game.start and game dot stop and so
that's why that design that's where that
design comes from as well but you can
see create a new thread and it passes in
this because this implements runnable
which is why we we can pass that in and
what that will do when you call
thread.start is call The Run function so
that's why that happened and also like
why am I creating an extra thread to run
the game on instead of just running it
on the main thread I believe that's
something to do with applets but I just
remember that's something that Notch
used to do and again I think that's
maybe it's because of outputs maybe it's
a stylistic thing but when I first
learned this stuff that was kind of just
what I I thought you had to do that and
there you go so now we have the whole
game running on a separate thread to the
main thread and that's why I believe
in stop we have like thread.join as well
to make sure we wait you know running
gets set to false running is a member
variable would be fantastic like you can
see I didn't use like any kind of
convention here M underscore like pixels
or anything like that it was just
straight names uh because again that's I
guess what Notch did but also
um you know the Java books I read did
that as well and also like the Amazon
convention is just something I picked up
at EA like that was not something that I
uh used at all prior to that even like
University and stuff I think University
and C plus plus
um like the lecturer did have a
convention but it wasn't like I think it
was like you know if you were passing
something into a into a function you
know like you'd have a p like for
parameter like that or something out the
front of it versus like anyways
something like that but basically
um yeah the whole game happens here you
can see there are some like literal
timers here to determine whether or not
we should update it that's why it only
gets 60 updates per second so there's
literally just a timer running and
that's how we decide there's no like
vsync or anything
um and then if system milliseconds like
minus last time greater than a thousand
so it's in milliseconds meaning if we
reach a thousand milliseconds so one
second passes we incremented by one
second so that we get to the next Second
and we print out like this and we do a
level update timer so basically this
block here only runs once per second and
so there's some very manual timing going
on here which again is is something that
games do nowadays as well but it's just
interesting seeing it kind of all laid
out like this
um and then yeah the update function
will kind of update the input which will
basically so you can see the input
Handler class just has all the controls
kind of hard coded here and in the
update function we just see whether or
not this massive Boolean of keys 65536
which is like just a 60 like a 16-bit
value basically
um because maybe the key codes can't go
above that I don't know why but whatever
the key code like what we have here is
just a Boolean array where we just have
every single key I guess that is
currently uh well it's state so if it's
false it's not pressed if it's
um true it's pressed which again is a
bit ridiculous to just allocate like an
array
um like that just so that we can
basically store every key at its index
and then like when we lose focus yeah
that's the other thing I think if you
like if I click somewhere else you can
see it says click to focus so I did like
a little Focus listener as well
um so that we could basically uh where's
this it was like the terminate button
here it is so that we could you know
make sure that we release like all of
the keys if we lose is focus and then
also if the game wasn't focused you have
the click to focus which again I
remember Notch did that as well and the
reason why he did that was because uh I
think sometimes if the game's embedded
in a web browser like as an applet you
know you might have the page focused but
not the applet and so you have to click
on it and so that way you know just in
case you like booted up a page and we're
reading through like you know how to
play the game or whatever and you were
like oh why the controls not working
it's because the applet wasn't actually
focused and so I think that's why that's
there
um but yeah so that's kind of uh how all
of that works and
then we have okay so what happens and
this is like some really interesting
programming going on here oh man this is
some of this is coming back to me okay
so this play menu biome this is kind of
funny so when you're learning
programming uh and again like everyone's
experience is probably a little bit
different but I remember one of the
things that I really really really
struggled with was like how do I
link two things together if I have this
game class here right and I know that
for example I have inside the update
function like I want to say load a
different level based on what is picked
in the main menu
the main menu you know correctly so
contains all of the stuff related to the
main menu so if I have like you know a
play button and let's just say someone
either selects a specific level or in
this case I believe you can't select a
level it just randomly assigns you with
a level if the main menu is the thing
making the decision of which level we
play so for example like I guess you
know index two or like id2 then how do I
communicate that to the game so that the
game knows which level to load because
the main menu doesn't really load the
level you know the game should do that
and I just remember struggling with this
stuff so much so what I would kind of do
as like a little you know inexperienced
programmer trying to make this stuff
work is a lot of times I would just make
the variable say static because that
means that obviously if the variable
static it's kind of global and I can
just access it in any class that I need
it now from a design point of view you
know this isn't the best thing to do but
it definitely worked and you can see
over here what I've kind of done is I've
just accessed like the play menus biome
to see what what it has been selected to
what its value is so that I can do the
appropriate thing and you can see here
as well that if play menu biome equals 2
then we basically create a new instance
of this ocean level which is a specific
like level I guess ocean level you can
see just loads like ocean.png but
otherwise it's just a level so I just
decided for some reason to make I guess
all of these class instances so let's
see what all the levels are I guess here
yeah there's like forest level there's
snow level this is a little bit of a
weird decision as well I basically had
all these classes uh you know which were
like subclasses of this like superclass
called level but the only thing they did
is they called The Constructor of level
but with a specific
like level file to load so like why
would you do that why would you create
an entire class just to set this piece
of variable data basically it's either
snow.png or forest.png I think there's
like island or something.png as well or
maybe forest was like the name of the
island well anyway the point is that's
ridiculous because what I could have
done is just called like level with the
path straight up from game or even just
had some kind of like array of levels I
guess like the way I would probably
write this nowadays if I had to was I'd
have like some kind of like if the
levels were hard coded like that into
the game you know I'd probably just
write I probably just have like an array
of like three strings or something
called levels and then I'd I haven't
actually written Java code in years I
have no idea what the syntax is but
basically you know I would just do this
just you know control tab does not work
um you know what was it snow and fire uh
snow and ocean
you know I would just do something like
that and what that means is that if we
come over here and we're trying to load
a particular level instead of trying to
make an entire you know instance of that
specific class that I've written just to
contain that string essentially you can
just set level equal to new level with
you know the path being levels at
whatever index biome you've selected
such as this one and that one would of
course correspond to that one so this is
probably what I would do these days
again back then I was probably like oh a
raise like what do they do I'm sure I'm
just sort of raised by this point but my
brain just I guess wasn't working kind
of like it is now which is
understandable this was 10 years ago and
I think I think this like by then by by
the time I made this game I had probably
about one year of experience and
experience is a very loose word here
because my experience was again like
Java for dummies try like programming in
all of my spare time trying to learn
this stuff and watching like notches
live streams that was probably my that
was my entire experience like I remember
trying to to go to people at school in
high school and being like hey can you
help me with this code no one new
programming like you know the I.T
subjects that we're taught were like you
know PHP databases you know uh HTML
mostly like there was almost no one who
actually understood like programming and
so it was kind of difficult for me
things got better in University but yeah
it was a little bit rough but I got
there in the end didn't I so there's
there's always hope so yeah that's kind
of funny and now I guess we make a
female so I I'm kind of skimming through
this stuff but I hope like I hope this
is easy to follow you know you play the
game you launch up the main menu which I
didn't really show because I don't know
if that's worth showing but basically
the main menu is just a little bit
horrific because there's all these like
hard-coded variables I think one of the
things that was a problem I remember
um sure was uh
you know I basically responded to like
key pressed but it would just like you
know because because the key would be
pressed for longer than a frame you know
like you you can't press a key that
quickly if you even held it down a
little bit it would just skip over to
like you know the next menu item and I
tried to delay that and the way I
delayed that is because you can see it's
kind of delayed if I hold it it still
goes so it doesn't really I don't have
to let go of like the up arrow and then
press it again to get to the next one it
just skims over it but it does so slowly
and the reason why is because there's
like literally a timer here that says
hey man only like go into this Branch if
I'm trying to go down to the next menu
item if the time is at zero uh and
otherwise if the timer is greater than
zero it will kind of decrement the timer
so that basically means that you can
only advance to the next menu option
after like 10 frames of having gone
through one because that resets it back
to 10 if that makes sense so that was my
kind of strategy for delaying it which
is a little bit weird I guess nowadays
like that I'm not sure there would even
be a problem but if I had used events
for example I could make sure that you
basically have to you know physically
release the key and make sure it's
pressed again because if we only respond
to key pressed events where we have a
repeat count and that repeat count is
zero and we only actually kind of you
know you know dispatch the event or like
handle the event let's just say advance
to the next menu option if that repeat
count is zero that would have worked
fine and that's how I'd probably do it
at like in Hazel you know these days but
back then of course I knew nothing about
that what what are events like that
didn't really make sense so that's why I
had this kind of state of input case and
I dealt with that and then basically all
it does is it it um
you know we have these all these
different menus but otherwise I think
what it does is you can see uh so if we
do in fact press
I guess the enter key so this is all the
rendering
um yeah then you can see that okay so
what it used to do was it used to set
the biome to a random uh integer I guess
between zero and two inclusive but now
it just it's hard coded too because I
think even though I had different
different like biomes I guess different
like Maps uh the only one that really
played well was that Island one and so
that's why that's the one that we saw
here and that's why I ended up hard
coding that to two I guess so to make
sure that it actually played that even
though like oh so ocean is that one
right yeah Forest is different and snow
is different yeah so ocean is the one we
play that's the island one so that's
kind of interesting how that works um
but I'm kind of skimming through this
but the the point is that you know we're
in here update you know biome number two
has been selected it's time for us to
play so again everything is stemming
from this game class which is not really
great there's no like State machine
there's no like what scene should I be
rendering now here's the main menu scene
when I press enter you know tell the
scene manager or something to advance to
the game scene there's none of that it
all is Just Happening inside like this
one game class and there's basically
just a real-time kind of in every update
like function call there is an if
statement there's a branch that says
what am I supposed to be doing and in a
way this is working like a state machine
because it's saying if the biome is to
load the level but then obviously set
the biome to negative one so that next
frame we don't wind up loading the level
again because when when our plane level
so it's kind of interesting and then if
biome zero is selected that's the forest
level of volume one is selected that's
the snow level again you can see there's
like a bunch of code here that's kind of
repeated-ish you know this is like
presumably okay so this is us creating a
new female which is a mob that has like
a I guess a fixed Swan position or
something even though we're supposed to
I guess randomize that and then we add
like the player to the level and we set
its spawn point manually like that and
this is funny because it's happening all
inside that update function which is a
bit of a disaster you know you'd want to
kind of do this in like a different
place completely and then obviously for
that female as well we set its spawn
position so basically you know the map
you know this little Island map that
looks so roughly like this or whatever
and then surrounded by like you know
water everywhere
um it gets kind of loaded and then the
players like player gets set here and
then the female gets set there so that
way you kind of have that starting point
and that will always be the same we have
this population uh counter I guess which
oh no this does more than count doesn't
it okay so you can see it has a
population count you start with two
because obviously you have the player
and you have the female and then the
growth uh is kind of like
that's the rate at which it grows and
you can see the population here is just
plus equals growth and they're both
doubles here and so that will grow and
then okay so every 800 population
will actually add a new oh okay so
that's why we were actually seeing more
females appear wow I forgot about this
entirely because simply every 800
population
you we will just spawn in for the ocean
level a new ocean mob which
I guess but is that going to be a female
or not or is that just more more and
more I think that that might just be
um
oh here we go if level is not but that's
no but that's specifically for the
forest level which this isn't I think
this will just populate it with just
normal mobs basically to just make it
appear as if there's more population
because obviously it's growing yeah
that's probably why because obviously
the number's getting so much higher but
we're not really seeing visually more
and more people so that's probably why
that's there
um and then yeah this this class also
will render
all of that kind of population text
um so that's kind of what happens there
but otherwise we just have a level
update which will update all of the
entities so this part is kind of more or
less correct and more or less what you
would expect from like a normal game you
know we have like this class called
level which is like our our kind of it's
like a scene it's like the container for
all of the entities inside there and all
the tiles which make up the game world
so we have a list of tiles uh analysts
and Javas it's the same thing as like a
listen C sharp which is just like a
resizable array
of contiguous memory and we have entity
as well which we just have all of our
entities here and um so the player you
know all the mob is basically are all of
your entities potentially like the
Torches as well for those light tiles
are there as well
um and then we just have so we load the
level from the file that's where
everything begins and that's just us
reading in the image file and basically
going through getting every single color
um that we have in there and adding that
all into this tiles array and this tiles
array is what determines
um you know basically I think that's
just like a it's a it's the same it's a
one-dimensional array that just contains
all of the tiles in our level and you
can see that there's this function
called get tile which basically you just
give it a coordinate if it's like out of
bounds it will kind of give you I guess
the ice tile or avoid tile and depending
on some
different parameters yeah I guess if
it's out of bounds it'll give you a void
tile unless it's a uh the Star level in
which case it'll give you the eyes tile
but basically
um uh otherwise you can see it will
literally read the color value so these
the reason why these numbers are so kind
of big is because the levels as I
mentioned I don't know if I can find
them here levels
short ocean yeah so you can see here
that there's like this is kind of low
resolution but we have all these colors
here
um and the different colors correspond
to different tiles right so basically uh
we just read the value of the pixel I
guess in that coordinate in the image
essentially but we've copied the image
data into this tiles array to see like
hey is this like the color and there's
FF here because the alpha channel is
always going to be you know full Alpha
and then it's like RGB or BGR I don't
know but basically uh based on that we
return the right tile and that
presumably is used inside like the
render function here which you can see
goes through everything and
um yeah and we'll just like render the
appropriate tile we do get tile and then
we do tile.render and you can see as
well that the way I've made this is
instead of just physically drawing the
pixels like a normal person this is
basically like a base class called tile
and then there's tile.render which is a
function implemented by all of these
tiles and this to me is madness
um this is very interesting because this
is such an object-oriented approach to
programming and I like this is basically
just not just style of programming not
just style of programming was very
object oriented like it would have been
because I'm pretty sure this is where I
got this from I mean I'm sure but the
books I read were also very object
oriented but like I just remember Notch
did it specifically this way
um and he just loved this kind of stuff
and so he would basically have like you
know a class for everything you have
like a specific stone stone tile which
can override some certain functions even
something as simple as like public
Boolean solid so is it can you walk
through it or can you not walk through
it that is like a function inside like
it's like a virtual function inside a
subclass inside a derived class that
answers that question right and then you
also have
um you know public void render which is
something you override that sells that
says how to render this tile but again
the the problem that I have with this
these days and it's interesting just how
again object oriented it really is but
the reason why this is kind of not how I
would do things these days is because
what it means is like just look how many
classes you need and I mean Java
programming is a lot like that or at
least back then it was it was very much
about classes because as I mentioned
there were no lambdas back then you know
you had to create classes if you wanted
any kind of like
function you know to pass in a function
somewhere but you can see that the like
what this does is identical for like
everything I'm assuming this is false by
default it is and so that's why you have
certain things that are solid like you
know the
um I don't know is I solid yes like you
know eyes and like Stone I think we had
as well
all that stuff specifically returns true
um but render tile is like the same you
know maybe torch or like some of these
are a bit different but more or less
it's the same the other thing you might
notice is we have this like left shift
four now this is also uh influenced by
notch because he wrote this a lot and
the reason why so for those of you who
don't know a bit shift left by four well
whenever you're really bit shifting left
all right what you're doing is you're
either multiplying or dividing by 2 to
the power of n where n is this number
here so basically shifting left by four
what that's doing is that's simply
taking X and it's multiplying it by 16
because 2 to the power of 4 is 16.
that's what we're doing here so this
code could be Rewritten as this now why
are we multiplying by 16 because now
we're trying to render pixels on the
screen and this gets passed in as a
coordinate so we have like picture the
level is just made up of like a grid of
pixels and we have a coordinate you know
like five comma five where we want to
like five x five Y where we specifically
want to like render you know our tile
let's just say it's over here
um so to actually figure out what pixel
on our screen we need to start rendering
from we need to multiply it by 16 to
kind of translate it or like transform
it from that kind of you know uh grid
index space or grid coordinate space
into pixel space and so we multiply it
by the size of each tile and each tile
was 16 by 16 pixels that's why you're
seeing this now why was it written as a
shift Left 4 instead of time 16 because
I believe well again because Notch did
that why did he do that I think
something about this being faster
because a bit shift is faster than a
multiply but again these are things that
I would really expect the compiler to
just do for you if it says that you're
trying to multiply by a power of two and
it's an integer you know it should
probably
just convert that into being you know a
bit shift if that instruction is faster
on the CPU it's running on and because
Java is all virtual machine based it can
probably just do that on the fly but
again like I don't know the intricate
details of java and what do I really
care so let's move on uh we'll go back
to level and we'll see how the rest of
the tiles are rounded but basically yeah
that's what happens and that's why
x-scroll you know here is dividing by 16
to get from like this x column y scroll
which would be in pixel space into like
a grid coordinate over here as well and
that's kind of I think what this is
doing is based on the scroll which is
basically just the position of well this
this I believe if we go back to game and
just check out render for a second I
believe what this would be
is basically
um yeah you can see X crawl is Playa x
minus screen with divided by two so what
that's doing is it's taking the player X
but then it's shifting it a bit so that
we basically Center this so screen wave
divided by two screen height divided by
two that's obviously going to be the
center of the screen but also we're
offsetting it by the player X and Y to
get like a level position but centered
um well kind of a level position but
shifted and the reason why is because we
basically want to say okay well if the
player is here you know if we know that
the player is over here let's offset the
player's X and Y by half the screen
width and height so that we basically
get you know if we subtract and subtract
let's just say going up is subtracting
um then we get this and the reason why
is because we then want to render from
this space forward so that the player is
nicely centered and that's the X crawl
and Y scroll we passed into level render
and that's kind of the offset of all the
pixel coordinates x0x1 y0 y1 that's just
determining the bounds so we basically
have uh the horizontal bounds so from
this x coordinate to this x coordinate
then the vertical balance from like this
white coin I think you know positive y
was actually going down so that would be
like this would be like y zero and then
this would be like you know y1 so we've
determined bounds and everything within
those bounds is going to basically get
rendered and again we divide by 16 to
get into that grid space and I believe
what that does along with this little
scrim with plus 15 to make sure we also
include a partial tile so if a couple of
I remember all this well it's not I'm
I'm deducing a lot of it from the code
I'm seeing but I'm a lot of it is from
memory as well so what this will do is
basically if we have a tile that's like
because obviously we're moving around
the screen you know you might have
partial tiles in view it's not like it's
moving based on tiles you can move
smoothly between tiles
um and so because of that if we have
something like that I think what we're
doing is we're adding 15 or whatever
Plus screen width but also plus 15 to
get us over the edge so that this
actually does get included or something
like that
um and if we go plus 16 it will include
like two so we're doing like the max
value of I guess one or something but
then we also Loop through that kind of
view and we retrieve the appropriate
tiles and we rendered them and again
that will just go to a class called
screen
and the class called screen just
contains the actual rendering this is
what actually sets pixels and so what
that will do is basically render tile
you can see again it does like some kind
of offset uh because you can set an
offset into screen I believe to offset
so that that offset there actually in
level was used just to get the index so
this is like a tile index offset now we
have to offset the pixels as well and
that's what this kind of XP minus X
offset is this gets set by a function
called like set offset that much I
remember here it is
um and that again gets set from the main
game class and then we go through and
you can see for the size of the Sprite
we do some checks here to make sure
we're in bounds basically and also clip
which is this is incorrect you don't
want to clip like this so I had a break
here whereas I should have probably had
a continue and that's why we have to
have this but I don't know if you guys
noticed but you can see that see that up
there so this actually says that if it's
out of bounds just set it to zero
instead of break instead of like
continuing I believe if we we had
actually how to continue and then I
believe instead of like this I don't
know why why this would be here but
instead of this if we just maybe set
this to like zero sort of it's less than
zero it doesn't actually do anything we
probably would just get rid of that yeah
so you can see we fixed that bug rather
easily but I believe the reason why I
didn't do that is because remember guys
we're literally rendering every pixel
one at a time here by setting a color
into an array and so because of that I
think what I had noticed was that if we
break instead of continuing like break
is faster than continue why because
break will abandon that entire for Loop
whereas continue we'll just go to the
next iteration and check again and so I
think because of that I distinctly
remember this I was like okay break is
faster so let's just do break and then
we'll also like do you know this in here
to make sure that
um we clip it or and we don't crash
basically so a bit of a weird solution
but sure that's kind of what I had uh
had going on there um and then yeah we
do some kind of where this class called
China color because the color was
already taken by Java so I had a little
China color class which did a bunch of
like uh you know this is just it
extracting all the channels from the
kind of integer color here and
brightening them by a pretty color
amount okay so this is how the day night
cycle worked we could tint it I guess a
specific color by just adding that value
to RGB
um and then like you know clamping it
basically
and then also we could change the
brightness of something by just yeah
just adding it you can just add like to
each Channel you just add the brightness
and that obviously makes the color
brighter so interesting
um that was kind of cool to see I
haven't looked at that in a while yeah
well anyway
um this is kind of dragging on but uh
very interesting to look through a lot
of this code uh the rendering
specifically is kind of interesting
because it's not Hardware accelerated at
all this is all kind of software
rendering we're literally setting pixels
on the CPU here into like an array and
that pixels array I believe is what we
eventually draw back in the game class
we have this like buffer strategy that
we get from the canvas because remember
this is kind of extending canvas and so
we get buffer strategy uh and then
that's like into into the buffer
strategies draw Graphics that's what we
kind of use here to actually
um I guess we passed that in so that we
can do things like drawstrings because
draw strings was drawn using Java's API
but all the tiles all the mobs they're
all drawn pixel by pixel using this
actual card here so I kind of in a way
software rasterizing it's not really
rasterizing because there are triangles
it's just pixels but yeah that's kind of
cool
um kind of miss doing things that way
and then you can see at the end this is
how we actually draw it so we um that
pixels is actually tied that pixel's
array is tied to an image which we then
copy by the way here so we actually set
pixels I equal to screen pixel's eye
this is a redundant step that I would
remove why have this copying of the
whole buffer of pixels over here if
you can just maybe you can presumably
just access the this pixels array
because you can see this pixels array is
image so this actually go comes from
image get Ross to get data buffer get
data that's what gives us that array of
pixels that if we like whatever we write
into here that is tied to the image that
we then draw over here so instead of
doing that like you could literally
probably just set screen dot pixels
equal to this same thing and that way
when you write into it from the screen
class it's actually writing into this
memory again something I'm sure I didn't
understand back then but that would
prevent this kind of essentially it's
like a mem copy of the whole buffer
um that would probably be an
optimization I would expect and then
the other thing I believe I could do is
width and height you can see is actually
300 and then also width divided by a 16
10 aspect ratio to get the height right
um and the scale is three what that
means is that when we actually launched
this this is a 900 wide window not 300
because we multiply it by three but we
ran it to an image that's kind of uh you
know three times smaller it's only 300
by you know whatever that is and so
actually we can probably hover over this
and see it yeah 300 by 180 and that
obviously speeds it up because we're
rendering less pixels and then we're
just kind of up sampling it or scaling
it up without filtering presumably by
eventually drawing the image add get
width and height which is the resolution
of the canvas because get with and get
high would be you know from the
component which a canvas is a component
so that's kind of a an interesting way
to create both a pixelated look because
everything is kind of lower resolution
then scaled up but also improve the
performance like dramatically
essentially because I believe we just
you know set this to one and made this
900 of course we're pushing way more
pixels now and you can see it's a little
bit weird we can see a lot more of the
island actually but you can see it's
down from like 1500 to 1700 fps to like
400 still not bad but remember back in
2012 you know with whatever lower spec
computer I had back then but also you
know 10 years ago computers in general
were slower uh this would would maybe
not even have run at 60. so
um yeah it's kind of interesting
uh but yeah that low resolution look I
guess was also part of the aesthetic
um that I presumably wanted to have in
this game uh yeah I mean that's it to be
honest like I mean yeah there's a lot of
really weird decisions lots of like
hard-coded numbers lots of like stuff
being not in the right place not knowing
how to uh you know tie classes together
I don't know if it's worth me kind of
demonstrating how I would fix these
things I just feel like you know to me
these a lot of these are so Elemental
that I feel like you guys just don't
need help with that and it's like you
know it's understandable like you can
see the problems but maybe that's just
me like with my current experience
obviously looking at this looking at
Young Cherno here I was but 17 when I
wrote this code
um you know looking at this stuff and
just being like what is this kid like
doing like obviously this is not how you
do certain things and so a lot of these
mistakes are kind of I guess obvious but
maybe they're just obvious to me so if
you guys want me to like show how I
would fix some of these things how I
would create better relationships then
drop a comment below let me know but
otherwise thank you guys for watching
this code review they're still like
probably quite a lot of stuff I would go
into
um I mean to be honest to be fair we
have like calculated quite a bit I
didn't really talk about like the on
there was supposed to be Predator mobs
that tried to kill you but I think I
caught that feature you can see there's
even health and stuff in the code base
but I believe that just got caught
because it's a lot of them dare and I
just didn't have time to do all of that
stuff we've covered most of this stuff
the AI kind of for those like I guess
females so the way they move is actually
random like it's just just random I
think what happens is basically
um yeah we just like every like we just
we have a random uh integer you know out
of 40 and if it's zero so there's like a
one in forty chance of hitting this
Branch basically every frame uh it will
just pick a random direction to move in
so basically you know we might pick up
as a random Direction so the mob's
moving up moving up and then what a 1 in
40 chance for it to be like I'll
actually go left now and that's it and
so it's just completely random like the
the entire movement which uh you know is
a bit weird but that's just that's
easy easy let them dare AI just make it
move make it randomly change direction
every now and then and you basically get
something that more or less you know
seems like it has a life of its own
which is it's it's that easy anyway
thank you guys for watching I hope you
have a really good festive period I hope
you've all had a really good year and
just take a break relax you know soak in
the festivities check out brilliant
using my link in description below and I
will see you guys later love you all
goodbye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]